Now, as
Russia faces widespread condemnation
over its war in Ukraine,
Cuba has emerged
as one of Moscow's biggest supporters.
The two countries, both are subject to US
sanctions are seeking to deepen
economic ties
through trade and investment.
CNN's Patrick
Oppmann reports now from Havana.
A Russian warship sails in Havana,
Cuba, greets the ship the Periscope,
the first Russian naval vessel
to make an official visit in years
with a cannon fire salute.
It's just the latest sign
of the forging of ties
between Russia and Cuba.
Well, much of the rest of the world
has denounced Russia
for their invasion of Ukraine.
Cuban President Miguel Diaz-Canel,
seen here alongside
Vladimir Putin
inaugurating a statue of Fidel Castro
in Moscow in November,
defends Russia's war on the ground.
We are saying we are condemning
we are rejecting the expansion of Miro
towards Russia's borders,
he told Russia today.
We condemn all the measures and sanctions
that have been applied as a way
to coerce the Russian Federation.
In Russia,
increasingly is
throwing a lifeline to their old ally
just 90 miles from the United States.
Since the
war in
Ukraine began, Russia and Cuba
have signed a flurry of new agreements
that would open the four supermarkets
selling Russian food here,
increased oil shipments to the island.
Even developed this beachside community
outside of Havana.
It appears to be the most significant
Russian investment in Cuba in decades.
In February, after Russia donated 25,000
tons of wheat, Russia's
then ambassador to Cuba
said the aid will continue to flow okay.
Cuba.
In spite of the challenges, he says,
Russia and Cuba
continue developing
their strategic relationship
based on the historic friendship,
solidarity and mutual sympathy
between our two countries.
Some of the Soviet thinking came
the warming of ties for many Cubans
feels like a trip back to the future.
In this video from the 1960s
narrated by Fidel Castro.
Cubans are told how visiting
Russian experts
would modernize the island
Instead, Cuba grew
dependent on Soviet aid.
The USSR collapsed and facing
punishing U.S. economic sanctions.
The island plunged into a financial abyss
from which it is yet to emerge.
Well, Russian
officials have suggested
reestablishing a military presence
on the island.
Some analysts feel that Moscow
no longer has the capability to do so.
I think this kind of threats
are used
more for taunting the United States
and for kind of
for war
is a kind of
a form
of psychosis,
psychological warfare,
kind of psyop against the United States.
Whatever the future of the renewed ties.
It's clear
Russia is once again
staking a claim in Cuba.
Patrick Oppmann, CNN, Havana.